i have not played a horror game in pitch
blackness in a very long time oh god
it's dark okay all right i guess we're
starting out pretty early seven four six
zero
nah oh oh that was it there's a cave up
here or something there's usually some
goodies in the cave
oh
god eh like if you turned out all the
lights and just stayed up and oh my
god why what happened wait oh my god
he's so quick he's so quick oh no he's
coming for me oh there he is
no no no not fair not fair not fair
oh you threw that
holy crap
okay i get your pissed i get your pissed
i get it i get it can you leave me be
where even are you
you freaking shadow in the night
oh i hate you
i hate you oh i'm out of here
well that's annoying okay i'm gonna go
this way now
[Music]
there's no need oh i need to heal no
oh which one
oh god are you still coming this way
oh there you are
okay he's not running towards me so i
think i'm okay oh he has healed up a lot
of the damage that i did but
the gray bar is only so big compared to
the full health bar so i did do some
permanent damage to him
and i am still doing okay as far as
supplies go let's just give him a cat
and mouse at this point i just gotta
find the um
the zip lines and take advantage of them
gonna ignore that
oh fuel canister okay that is helpful
to make a bomb
i think if i turn those on doesn't does
it actually confuse him
does it make him check the sounds i
don't know i i still to this day i don't
know how bigfoot's logic works
i know he's a philosophical fellow but
that doesn't mean that i can understand
the inner machinations of his mind
her mind
okay there's something here because
the trail runs
to a dead end just under this cliff
oh what is this
oh no
no
no
it seems like there should be so aha
okay something it's something
old hunting tower one okay it's
something
trap maybe
just one flare gun bullet and that's it
all right
good
okay we got some kind of a cabin
ooh see that's green 9948
9948 that's green i don't know what
you're talking about
there nothing there
nothing there
sure
oh
okay
maybe that other one was yellow oh
interesting another weapon for this slot
but
i'll take automatic any day holy crap
maybe i got a chance not a good chance
remember it's still me so i could find a
way to screw it up somehow
bam
i forgot i could do that all right i'm
full health i got a rifle
i got some bravery oozing out of me i'm
ready to take on bigfoot after i get a
few more things do i have any traps i do
have one trap what is this
red tail campground another fuel can oh
i can't take that interesting
so is there some way that i do i have to
build the trap
there's no crafting i have objectives i
didn't know i had objectives
find powerful weapons and ammo
set traps in ambush ambush i'm supposed
to ambush bigfoot is that what i'm oh
god
[Music]
well
win some lose some
i won that one there's some kind of
chair lift there
fascinating yeah i don't know what
that's about if i could sit on the chair
lift i'd be very happy
but also i don't know where the chair
lift is going i don't even know if i can
get up there
uh
weird a ski run there's a whole ass ski
run here oh
no thank you
okay well camera on the ski run
and let's see what it is you're not
coming up here are you
god you better not be
i mean it seems to be an isolated run up
the mountain
it doesn't exactly have zip lines down
but i didn't know this was here
alright
ah
i think someone might have made a last
stand here of some kind
me in a few minutes
yeah oh again oh god why do i not
listen
the freaking sounds are there
how do i not see those
oh
that must be the sound of bigfoot
setting up traps
which is unnerving
why bigfoot be able to do that
i don't like that
isn't there a way in here did i miss it
oh right here
okay well i'm gonna close this
i'm gonna assume that oh
great
i'm gonna assume that he's just gonna
make a b-line for me
and that's it
let me actually set up the uh drone
no uh
there and let me charge it because i
have so many batteries what i should do
oh god what was that okay he's all the
way over there that's good actually i'm
gonna set a trap here
inside and then i'm gonna put
a car freaking car battery
can i not do that i thought i could do
that
is that not how it works oh maybe it can
only be a certain distance from the trap
but if i do
fuel cancer i guess it's just another
trap if you think about it
all right
hopefully that'll settle itself and
these are all boarded up so he's really
only one point of entry even though that
does box me in
it gives me some semblance of a fighting
chance
so i'm just gonna take my chance
let's make it super dark i'm ready to
set up the trap
and i think i'm ready to shoot him if he
goes to the door there maybe i could zap
him i think there's a little bit of a
taser on the drone for some reason
this might be the end for me
this might be my last stand
oh there he is okay
i spy him i spy him i spy little i
i spy little i
i spy with little eye
where'd he go
here we go he was right here
oh oh god missed him
he's taking a shortcut
he's taking the shortcut he's b-lining
he's b-lining
and tasing
tasing tasing
tasing oh god
wasn't he right there
oh god
oh god this is bad
okay he's gonna get trapped
he's gonna get trapped
oh ow
that hurt a lot
he's hurt he's hurting not as much as i
would like
oh god i'm into flare meant to flare
didn't player didn't flare flare didn't
do didn't do flair didn't do little
little duda
recoil's big recoil's very big
where are you at where are you at come
here
come here come here come here come here
where you at where you at
right that's right three damage somehow
that's not very much
it's almost daytime what are you gonna
do about that
hey
hey
what are you gonna do
all right doing good
doing better anyway not great but good
enough
that's what i thought you're coming back
for more
well the recoil
i've almost got into half health
this is about as much as i can do
whoa
oh god that's not good
wow
wow
oh he's running away no he's running for
me no he's running away he's running
away i've got him on the ropes he's on
the ropes i'm running i'm running
i'm running away i'm running away
his roping he's roping he's roping
he's roping
might be doping might be pushing dope
i don't know
he's probably right behind me gonna
switch guns
okay that was a fairly successful night
didn't get him his down as much as i
would like but right now he's got about
half health plus
he could heal back up to about
two-thirds
which is good
that is a bit more progress than i've
had in the past so i will take that can
i get up there that way yeah i can get
up and around there seems to be
something at the top of this mountain
here only moderately concerned because
he should have been coming this way
unless he was running really quickly
he's probably still around here
somewhere
this cave no
see lights
see overlook see overhang see tent
delicious food
maybe a trap
well trap would be too much to ask for
lots of shotgun ammo i've got too much
shotgun ammo
oh it's been a bonanza but what am i
doing with the bonanz
pistol ammo i would never do anything
with that
night vision camera cool
ugh don't care about the lore they are
dead i'm not as long as i'm still
breathing i got a chance
ah propane
that's an explosive it didn't do a lot
of damage or if it did damage i wasn't
paying attention to the damage therefore
i don't know how much damage it did is
that another ski lift so this is based
on the uh old windows game or dos game
ski run with the yeti coming at you
i thought it was familiar hey there's a
way to get over there
that would be a pretty isolated place to
fight if i could get up there but this
one has a zip line
that's good oh it's only a gazebo
that's bad okay i'll take it whoa
fireworks hell yeah
okay
let's progress
first aid
i think i might actually make this
i think somehow
stay alive i'm trying
i'm really trying getting in anything in
here can i hide in one of these no i
can't even get in too thick oh should i
fight up here or should i take this back
to the rv
i don't know there's multiple
whoa
funky
hang gliding perfect if only i had a
hang glider
that would be great
i don't have that
but okay okay where does this go goes
down there
that one just goes down to the bottom
there's not one over there i guess i
just go down
i don't want to fight him up there
seems cowardly
oh another one i think i remember a call
of duty zombies map that gun has this
layout
um let me go to the end of the road over
here that's the only other place that i
see that i haven't gone
so if i can get over there
maybe i can find another trap and make a
sand out of this
that's what i'd like anyway but i can't
guarantee it's gonna happen the darkness
really does unsettle me i get used to it
for a bit i forget that i'm in darkness
and then i'll turn around and just be
pitch black
and there could be a yeti behind me
oh
a cave or what
not just another campsite
no shelter here
might take this back to big town
at least i got some kind of mobility
there
baseball that hell yeah
i've got guns for days weapons for days
uh not really much in the way of uh
traps i have one
fireworks and then i have one like
explodey barrel could make a pretty good
boom boom room but that's about it
then i'm on my own i gotta be mobile
this might be the final night for me
because i don't have any traps i've got
no flares whatever happens now is kind
of like down to the wire
i just it's just me
me and my
my husband
hello
i'm going back to the town oh there's
something down at the bottom here
nice
i don't know what i'd do with all the
meat
but uh here we go oh no oh no
oh shouldn't have done that
why did i bother to do that i just have
more meat on me maybe that's the thing
that dr oh trap i have a chance i have a
chance i have a chance ha now
s oh man these traps
these traps if this is bigfoot doing
that bigfoot's getting real crafty i
don't know why i'm not crafty why i
can't craft nothing that seems a little
silly i wish i could but uh it seems a
little unfair
i feel like if i had my tools you know i
could cut down some of these trees make
some traps i could do that
was bigfoot doing all day
just sitting around making traps
whittling it
thinking about killing me
how he's gonna cook me
that's no fun okay
let's start here what i'm gonna do is
i'm gonna start here
well that's bad sign but you know
start here because there's two doors
so what i'll do is i'll trap this bottom
one
and then uh
i'll go from there
all right i have no cameras left then
i'll jump down
let me just plan this
i could come around here
to two more doors through the bottom one
that would be nice i just don't know if
i'm gonna make it around before he comes
down and kills me but if that doesn't
work maybe it probably would be best to
moosie over there
all right
let's get the right tool for the job
shotgun and then i just i just keep
moving as best i can i think even though
this one's broken down
i still got this door here i'm gonna
leave it open and uh yeah let's hope for
the best let's put down trap
right here
actually let me move it to where he
absolutely cannot avoid it
and then i'll put the
oh actually let me take that i'll put
this at the bottom here
so i'll definitely get hit by that
fireworks here i guess i don't know i
don't know if that actually does
anything kind of sucks i can't put that
right on there
put meat on there
[Music]
okay no flare gun no point
g17 once this goes i close this door i
load into him
i lay into him i don't load into him i
unload into him
these doors will block him up for a bit
i make my way through there down there
just i keep going indoors best i can
that's all i can do i don't know why i'm
bothering with the pistol when i've got
literally any other weapon
oh god don't put don't do don't do that
don't do that
don't do that don't do that
don't do that
this is it
this is it
this might be the final night
if i can get him down i win
i win
oh here it comes here comes
okay
okay yeah yeah yeah your head hurts huh
yeah you don't like that do you shotgun
does do a lot
that didn't go well
okay
okay um wow all right
uh
where'd you go where'd you go where'd
you go where'd you go
you come back up
you're already back up
okay he's not trying to break down the
door yet weirdly enough
come here you
you're not done you're not done
we're doing this
come on
where you at where you at there you are
here he comes
oh boy okay we're going we're going next
place
next locale nook's locale go go please
go go go please go go please go go go
please oh my god
come here come here come here
ow
okay uh oh that went way quicker than i
thought it would
i thought i had uh more time i must have
pressed the wrong button oh god this is
the wrong one that's the literally the
only one that doesn't have that clothes
all right
come here where you at
where you at
where you at
there you are
yeah come here
run away
no don't run away he's not running away
okay
okay
okay
okay okay okay
he's done that one's done
okay next one
[Music]
come on
59
come on
good shots oh god not good shots
[Music]
okay
gotta go gotta go gotta go gotta go
gotta go what do i got what do i got
left oh my god
i need to put a gps sensor in where are
you
where are you
hello
did he run away
he's almost dead he's got 89 i should
have just shot him
damn it i was right there oh where'd you
go buddy where'd you go you're mine
you're mine bigfoot oh he's healing up
big foot
big foot
where'd you go big boy big girl okay a
little more time left oh
that was a little concerning um i'm
gonna go
and i'm going to check a few more
locations that i overlooked because i
was in a hurry now let's get addling and
i'm gonna get bit more stuff and then
i'm taking down bigfoot bigfoot's
basically mine i gotta hunt him down now
which is what i should have been doing
from the beginning and kind of the point
of this game is
i think it's finding bigfoot or i think
it's now just called bigfoot
whoa
i'm sorry
what is this
what in the hell
that's cool
um
i'm gonna assume that this isn't magic
and this is kind of like by design
okay that's very strange i don't know
what's powering these lights but
kind of cool i think
ooh cabin
this might be a good final stand cabin
oh again again
how many times does bigfoot gonna give
me with those things bigfoot really is
the best hunter
i'm just playing his game
her game
hell yeah
another fuel canister
that'll do
well
acts big
well yeah
this is the only thing that i haven't
seen the code for oh oh
well handy that that's right there
9610 let's find out what's in the last
case i guess
wow
dynamite
okay
well if you're just gonna hand me the
win can i bring uh can i bring bigfoot
back in pieces is that uh is that how
this is gonna work is that all right
by the commission or the
whatever organization kind of
coordinates this stuff the bigfoot
research association aren't i in charge
of that no that's jake
i'm jessica which means that uh i think
yes i think i can definitely do that so
i'm going to do that big
sorry i'm sorry i'm sorry
see where this goes
the cross down there
that's cool
this is all very cool
it's cold actually
sorry i would think that there would be
a structure at the top of the hill but
maybe not
oh my god
okay it's almost night
that makes sense i have no more traps
i first stayed
fireworks
fuel cancer and
literally dynamite
i don't remember the button to blow it
up but i think it was g
oh god is this the cave okay only
fitting that i try to kill him in his
own ho oh come on
ow
every time
oh i guess i could do this
all right i'm in this cave i've already
been in here which means i've already
taken the stuff that is here
but if i can beat him in his own cave
i'm sure he'll be really pissed
so i'm gonna do that
because i'm not trying to just beat him
i'm trying to disrespect him
that's what i'm about and that's what
i'm going to be about
when i do that
how do i
all right there it is i guess first i'm
going to burn him
then i'm going to blow him up then i'm
going to give him the show of his life
first i'm going to lure him in
then i'm going to burn him and then i'm
gonna blow him up what if i finish him
off with fireworks i doubt i will
but i'm gonna try how about this
the fireworks right here so that
so he gets a really nice show you know
maybe i shouldn't set those off
whoops oh god i didn't mean to set it
off
whoa
that was awesome
wow
i'm in his house
oh oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ]
does that mean does that mean does that
mean is that what that means
oh my god
okay
okay g better be the button
it better be the button i swear to god
if you ain't the button gee
oh [ __ ] that's not enough oh my god
oh god you come back here you come back
here no you ain't going you ain't going
get back here
yes
[Music]
oh
oh you thought you could
run oh you thought you could run
oh you thought
oh he tried to run
oh
hell yeah
oh
i thought i might i thought i might at
least level up i thought
thought i was gonna
you know
level up well there you go
i did it
i found bigfoot
i did the thing
welcome to bigfoot gamer that was fun
that was that was quite fun quite an
adventure but i did it thank you
everybody so much for watching let me
know what you thought down the comments
below and maybe me and my friends can
actually beat bigfoot together but i
think bigfoot gets a lot tougher
more people you have to make it
balanced but also this was a fun
experience playing this in night vision
if you got other games like this that
might work well for a night vision mode
let me know down the comments below
thank you
and as always i will see you
in the next video
bye-bye
[Music]
you